[Música]
ah
que pienso en cuando me ven
un en efe
un pobre discapacitado
un ejemplo de vida
qué sentís cuando me ves
en el peine de sensibilizó
me sacaría en la mirada
si nunca tuvieron contacto con alguna
persona que tenga una discapacidad
encantado de conocerlos soy lukas aranis
más conocida como capucha soy periodista
que extiende la licenciatura de
administración y estoy trabajando para
una empresa internacional
como verán mi discapacidad es sólo
física no le elegí pero tampoco me quejo
es que soy de las personas que piensan
que toda la vida tiene un para que más
que un porqué
personalmente yo llevo mucho a mi
familia por no decirlo todo ellos son mi
papá darío de mi mamá maría y después
vienen mis dos hermanos pablo y tomás
como como parece una crianza con todo
hermano
jugamos juegos físicos en los cuales yo
siempre perdía porque para ellos soy
nomás no tenía ninguna ventaja es por
eso que en algún momento me gustaría
encontrar la lámpara de aladino y uno
sería para pedir los deseos comunes y si
no sería para pedir dos deseos
especialmente el primero que me haga un
cuerpo musculoso para aunque sea una
sola vez ganarles en estos juegos
físicos a mis hermanos y en segundo
lugar no es plata el que ponga todo este
cuerpo musculoso y trabado con la voz no
pueden ser que este cuerpo está siendo
hermano y esta voz de la verdad que
no creciera
es desde muy chicos me dejaron muy en
claro que iba a ser difícil que vuelva a
caminar y poco a poco pero en las
herramientas para que me puedan
desarrollar como una más siempre dejando
bien en claro que el estudio va a ser la
herramienta fundamental para igualar
oportunidades tanto el primario como el
secundario lo hice en escuelas normales
él no fue a ninguna escuela especial en
estas instituciones además de aprender
empecé a conocer a mis primeros amigos y
descubrir mi amor por el deporte que
hasta el día de hoy me siguen marcando
todo comenzó con el fútbol en los
recreos como todo nene yo quería jugar
al fútbol y saben que no sólo jugaba al
fútbol en muchas ocasiones era el
goleador de mi equipo porque la jugada
era que un compañero desbordara y yo
entrara de 9 llevándome como una
topadora todo puesto y de esa manera
metiera el gol
este amor por el deporte continúa un
tiempo después cuando al basque en silla
de ruedas en duda discapacitados unido
sciences' y continúa actualmente con a
rahue personalmente para mí es un estilo
de vida
aunque en la vida no todo es deporte hay
que estudiar así que en 2012 empecé es
crear licenciatura en administración en
la universidad nacional del sur
actualmente estoy en tercer año de los
cinco que tienen la carrera
y me queda recorrer en un tramo bastante
largo aunque a mí me costó mucho llegar
hasta acá y no me voy a rendir tan fácil
al tiempo y hubo una propuesta de una
vez de mis mejores amigos
para empezar a estudiar periodismo es
abocado a lo deportivo
y no estaba en mi mejor momento en el
estudio pero ahí es que sentí que era lo
que quería hacer y que era el momento de
hacerlo así que me dije a mí mismo y le
metimos para adelante unos meses después
es que llegó una propuesta para arrancar
una pasantía laboral algo totalmente
nuevo para mí porque nunca había
trabajado en ese momento tenía que
madrugar conocer nuevos compañeros de
trabajo un jefe y al cual responder y un
horario el cual cumplir algo totalmente
nuevo para mí pero que lo veía como un
desafío apto aquí a mi amiga hay que
permitir de ser como persona así que
dije lista vamos para adelante en ese
aumento hice muchos sacrificios
efe de ver series de gel a plane algo
que me encanta lo único que no dije la
siesta de recta sacrifique todo y además
se me tiempos libres los fines de semana
allí que cubría a mi equipo de rugby
argentino así que me pasaba todo el fin
de semana incluye el lunes de vuelta a
través de estudiar y a trabajar el año
pasado fue maravilloso para mí
hago una aclaración no sume nada más ya
con las dos carreras y el trabajo está
bajito es más
como siempre me faltó tiempo
pero en lo contexto porque así me
distinguió como uno de los diez jóvenes
sobresalientes de ella el país porque
entendió que mi historia
que le puede servir de motivación a
otras personas a la hora de encarar la
vida
esto para mí fue maravilloso porque me
pidió difundir mi historia y lo que esto
y aparte esta repercusión causó cosas
increíbles y personalmente este premio
fuego es especial también para mí porque
lo veo como un reconocimiento a todas
las personas que estuvieron atrás mío y
nunca me dejaron caer porque en forma
turística actitud y voluntad y si no
tengo a mi familia mis amigos que
estuvieron y están siempre no hubieran
logrado nada de lo que hice hasta ahora
pero en mi parte me conozcan un poco más
tengo en una de las denominadas
enfermedades raras que se llama
displasia fibrosa
es que me descubrieron al año y medio
esperan fractura y a partir de ahí
empecé a tratarme nos dé en el hospital
garraham en buenos aires y básicamente
lo que es el que nuevo hecho son muy
débiles y tienden a deformarse una caída
mía es casi seguro es una quebradura
además desde los 8 años estoy en silla
de ruedas
personalmente no reniego de la
discapacidad porque me considero una
persona feliz lo único me cuesta
aceptarme cuando me miro al espejo y se
preguntarán por qué porque veo cosas que
me deal de cuerpo no las tengo y en ese
momento me cuesta aceptarme pero al
final como me quiero mucho y me termino
el sector igual
la sesión nunca fue un impedimento
estuvo en la playa tú en la nieve y esto
en eventos deportivos que en este
deportivos que no estaban adaptados todo
es cuestión de voluntad y voluntad si
escucharon bien voluntad y voluntad mi
voluntad de ir y la voluntad y la
persona que me acompañe a mí para
llevarme
día a día las cosas más habituales para
ustedes
en caso de petra forman en mis pequeños
desafíos diarios levantarme de la cama y
al baño cambiarme son algunos de mis
pequeños desafíos diarios ni les cuento
ir a comprar para la esquina o tomarme
un taxi es cuestión de buscar la forma
para poder
hace 25 años vengo recorriendo un camino
en el cual hay estrellas que
transformando mi discapacidad en una de
mis virtudes no es un camino fácil
porque nunca lo terminas de recorrer ya
que estás aprendiendo día a día pero la
vida es tan preciada que iba al intentar
los minutos minutos a lo largo de este
camino me di cuenta de cómo ponerle el
pecho a una discapacidad además me
cuenta que todo es cuestión de mí y de
mi actitud ante los demás este
aprendizaje me llevo tiempo porque esto
tuve que aprender a conocerme a mí mismo
de esa firma en mí mismo todo el tiempo
y nunca conformarme personalmente para
mí la discapacidad no es una debilidad
es fuerza sabiduría y constancia para
aprender a vivir día a día
yo disfruto del día porque aprendí a
conocerme a mí mismo y porque aprendí a
disfrutar los pequeños momentos a plena
si yo pude superar distintas situaciones
que fueron muchas y de decir y de
distinto tipo pero al mismo tiempo sé
que hay cosas que no puedo hacer pero sí
sé que hay otras que si puedo hacer y
son muchas
vos que estás ahí seguramente tenés tus
problemas pero también como yo soñar y
agus te quiero preguntar cuál es el
desafío que vas a encarar a partir de
mañana para conseguir este sueño
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]